bienvenido de nuevo a comprensión de información y computación cuántica, mi nombre es John Watus y soy el director técnico de educación en IBM
Quantum, esta es la lección número 14 de la serie y es la segunda lección de la cuarta unidad, que trata sobre errores cuánticos
en la lección anterior dimos un primer vistazo a la corrección de errores cuánticos, incluyendo el código Shore de nueve qubit, que establece que
la corrección de errores cuánticos es posible en teoría; también analizamos la discretización de errores, que nos permite
corregir errores cuánticos arbitrarios en qubits proyectándolos efectivamente sobre inversiones de bit y de fase
en esta lección hablaremos del formalismo estabilizador, que es una herramienta matemática con la que podemos
especificar y analizar una amplia clase de códigos de corrección de errores cuánticos conocidos como códigos estabilizadores; esto incluye el código Shore de 9 qubit
junto con muchos otros ejemplos, incluyendo códigos que probablemente sean mucho más adecuados para dispositivos de computación cuántica reales
que el código Shore; no todo código de corrección de errores cuánticos es un código estabilizador, pero muchos lo son
incluyendo cada ejemplo que veremos en esta serie; sin duda existen errores cuánticos interesantes y potencialmente útiles
códigos correctores que no son códigos estabilizadores, pero tienden a ser bastante más complicados y, en cualquier caso, no hay
duda de que el formalismo estabilizador es una piedra angular en los fundamentos de la corrección de errores cuánticos, y lo
utilizaremos ampliamente en el resto de la unidad; aquí hay una breve descripción general de la lección: empezaremos con una breve discusión
sobre matrices de Pauli y productos tensoriales de matrices de Pauli, que pueden representar tanto operaciones sobre qubits como
mediciones de qubits, como explicaré, y en este contexto a menudo nos referimos a ellas como observables; luego volveremos y veremos
de nuevo el código de repetición y veremos cómo podemos describirlo mediante operaciones y observables de Pauli, lo que nos informará
y llevará a una discusión general sobre códigos estabilizadores, incluyendo varios ejemplos y propiedades básicas de los
códigos estabilizadores, y cómo podemos llevar a cabo las tareas fundamentales de codificación, detección de errores y corrección de esos
errores; comenzaremos la lección con una breve discusión sobre operaciones de Pauli, principalmente para sentar las bases del
formalismo estabilizador, pero también para observar algunos hechos clave y establecer terminología básica; primero, aquí están las
matrices de Pauli, incluyendo la matriz identidad 2x2, así como las tres matrices de Pauli no identidad, que denotaremos por
X mayúscula, Y y Z a lo largo del resto de la serie; las cuatro matrices son unitarias y hermitianas, y podemos
identificarlas con operaciones sobre un qubit, incluyendo operaciones que podríamos elegir realizar, así como errores, como
analizamos en la lección anterior; las matrices de Pauli no identidad X, Y y Z anticonmutan entre sí,
lo que significa que XY es igual a -1 * YX, XZ es igual a menos ZX, e YZ es igual
a menos ZY, y puedes verificar fácilmente estas relaciones haciendo las multiplicaciones; estas relaciones de anticonmutación
son muy simples, pero son de vital importancia en el formalismo estabilizador y en otros contextos, y concretamente
como veremos, estos signos menos que aparecen al intercambiar el orden de dos matrices de Pauli no identidad diferentes en un producto corresponden precisamente a la
detección de errores en el formalismo estabilizador; también tenemos las reglas de multiplicación listadas aquí; cada
matriz de Pauli es su propia inversa, lo que es consistente con el hecho de que son tanto unitarias como hermitianas, y si multiplicas dos matrices de Pauli no identidad diferentes
siempre obtendrás más o menos I multiplicada por la matriz de Pauli no identidad restante
en particular, salvo una fase global, Y es equivalente a X por Z, lo que explica nuestro enfoque en los errores X y Z en
la corrección de errores cuánticos; X representa una inversión de bit, Z representa una inversión de fase, y así, salvo una fase global, Y representa
ambos errores ocurriendo en el mismo qubit; estas cuatro matrices representan
operaciones, errores o la ausencia de un error en un único qubit, pero a menudo es conveniente hacer su producto tensorial
para realizar operaciones o errores en múltiples qubits; como punto de terminología, cuando nos referimos a una operación de Pauli de N qubits
nos referimos a un producto tensorial de cualesquiera n matrices de Pauli, como los ejemplos mostrados
aquí; también es común usar el término operación de Pauli cuando hay una fase global, pero para mantener las cosas lo más simples posible
voy a usar el término operación de Pauli para significar simplemente un producto tensorial de matrices de Pauli; el peso de una operación de Pauli de n qubits
es simplemente el número de matrices de Pauli no identidad en el producto tensorial; por ejemplo, el producto tensorial de n factores
de la matriz identidad 2x2 consigo misma es una operación de Pauli de peso cero; un producto tensorial de dos matrices X de Pauli
y un montón de matrices identidad tiene peso dos, y así sucesivamente; intuitivamente, el peso de una operación
de Pauli de N qubits es el número de qubits sobre los que actúa de forma no trivial, y es típico que los códigos de corrección de errores cuánticos sean
diseñados para que puedan detectar y corregir errores representados por operaciones de Pauli hasta cierto peso; podemos
pensar en las operaciones de Pauli de diversas maneras, incluyendo como operaciones realizadas intencionalmente mediante quantum gates, así como
errores, y también veremos en breve que las operaciones de Pauli pueden describir mediciones; a veces también es útil
pensar en las operaciones de Pauli como generadores de ciertos conjuntos en un sentido algebraico que quizás reconozcas
si estás familiarizado con la teoría de grupos; si no estás familiarizado con la teoría de grupos, no hay problema, realmente no es esencial
para esta lección, pero si te interesa estudiar la corrección de errores cuánticos en mayor profundidad, puede que encuentres que algo de
teoría de grupos básica es muy útil para eso; de todas formas, supongamos que P1 hasta PR son operaciones de Pauli de n qubits
así que P1 es una operación de Pauli de n qubits, P2 es una operación de Pauli de n qubits, y así sucesivamente; cuando nos referimos al conjunto generado por
P1 hasta PR, lo que queremos decir es el conjunto de todas las matrices que podemos obtener multiplicando estas matrices entre sí en
cualquier combinación y en cualquier orden que elijamos, tomando cada una tantas veces como queramos; veremos algunos ejemplos en un
momento, pero primero déjame mencionar la notación que usamos para denotar este conjunto, el conjunto generado por P1 hasta PR
es P1 hasta PR separados por comas dentro de corchetes angulares; es verdad que podría confundirse fácilmente
esta notación con la notación de Dirac, pero eso generalmente no ocurre y esta es la notación tradicional en la teoría
de grupos; aquí hay un ejemplo del conjunto generado por X, Y y Z, así que n es igual a uno en este ejemplo porque no hay
productos tensoriales y tomamos las tres matrices de Pauli no identidad como generadores; resulta que hay
16 matrices que se pueden generar formando productos que incluyen estas tres matrices, y puedes razonar esto
a través de las reglas de multiplicación que vimos antes; concretamente, por supuesto podemos obtener X, Y y Z así como la identidad
y de hecho también podemos obtener cualquiera de estas cuatro matrices multiplicada por I, 1 o menos I, y eso es
este conjunto se conoce comúnmente como el grupo de Pauli; también podríamos considerar el conjunto
generado solamente por X y Z, y en ese caso obtenemos la mitad del grupo de Pauli
y un último ejemplo, al menos por ahora: podemos considerar el conjunto generado por X tensor X y Z tensor Z, donde N es igual a
dos en este caso, y obtenemos solamente cuatro elementos esta vez, debido al hecho de que X tensor X y Z tensor Z
conmutan entre sí. Las matrices de Pauli y las operaciones de Pauli de N qubits en general describen
operaciones unitarias, ya sean errores o intencionales, pero también describen
mediciones. Para ser más precisos, partiendo de las tres matrices de Pauli no identidad, podemos asociar cada una de estas
matrices con una medición proyectiva definida en términos de sus valores propios y vectores propios, y aquí en pantalla
tenemos las descomposiciones espectrales de estas matrices, que nos ayudarán a aclarar esto. En esencia, cuando hablamos de una medición X,
una medición Y o una medición Z, nos referimos a la medición proyectiva definida por las proyecciones
sobre los subespacios propios de estas matrices, y comúnmente pensamos en los valores propios como los correspondientes
resultados de la medición. Por ejemplo, una medición X es una medición respecto a la base más/menos
de un qubit, o alternativamente podemos describirla mediante el conjunto que contiene las proyecciones ket más bra más y k
menos bra menos. Una medición Z, en cambio, no es más que una medición en la base estándar,
aunque, como dije, a veces identificamos los valores propios con los resultados de la medición, y si hacemos eso
entonces los resultados son más uno y menos uno, en lugar de 0 y 1 respectivamente. De hecho, podemos hacer algo
similar para matrices hermitianas arbitrarias, y el término observable se usa comúnmente en esta situación. Para las matrices de Pauli
y las operaciones de Pauli de N qubits en general, podemos realizar dichas mediciones de forma no destructiva usando
estimación de fase. Y para asegurarnos de que este diagrama quede claro: aquí estamos realizando las mediciones de forma no destructiva sobre
el qubit superior, mientras que el qubit inferior siempre se inicializa en el estado más, es decir, con un Hadamard aplicado a un
estado cero, porque así es como funciona la estimación de fase. Nota que, dado que los valores propios
son simplemente más uno y menos uno en este caso, solo necesitamos un qubit de control, que es el qubit inferior en este
diagrama. Más de uno sería un desperdicio, ya que solo hay un bit de precisión del que preocuparse. El valor propio
es o bien más uno o bien menos uno, y la medición ya es perfecta así. El resultado de esta medición,
es decir, la medición en la base estándar en el circuit, será cero para el resultado con valor propio más uno,
que corresponde al estado más en el caso de un observable X, y el resultado es uno para el valor propio menos uno
o el estado menos en este caso. Todo lo que acabo de decir se extiende de forma natural a las operaciones de Pauli de N qubits,
siempre que tengamos en cuenta que cuando hablamos de un observable, estamos hablando de medir los valores propios,
no de medir respecto a una base de vectores propios. Por ejemplo, considera la operación de Pauli de dos
qubits Z tensor Z. De nuevo, hay dos valores propios, más uno y menos uno, por lo que la
medición se describe mediante dos proyecciones. Observa en particular que la medición que asociamos con
este observable no es lo mismo que medir ambos qubits con una medición Z, es decir, una medición en la base estándar, sino que es una medición proyectiva de dos
resultados donde las proyecciones son sobre los subespacios generados por todos los vectores propios correspondientes a
cada uno de los dos valores propios, más uno y menos uno. Otra forma de pensar en esto es que los valores propios de un producto
tensorial son productos de los valores propios de las matrices individuales de las que tomamos los productos tensoriales, y
dado que menos 1 por menos 1 es igual a más 1 por más 1, por ejemplo, esta medición no
distingue entre 0 0 y 1 1. Así que si midiéramos, digamos, un estado de Bell phi más con la medición
descrita por este observable, estaríamos seguros de obtener el resultado correspondiente al valor propio más uno,
y el estado permanecería sin cambios, en lugar de colapsar a 0 0 o 1 1, que es lo que ocurriría si
realizáramos las mediciones en la base estándar sobre los dos qubits. Así que una medición Z tensor Z no es
lo mismo que realizar dos mediciones Z de forma independiente, pero de hecho podemos realizar mediciones como esta usando estimación de
fase exactamente de la misma manera que antes, usando un único qubit de control, como se muestra en el diagrama del circuit,
que se generaliza a cualquier operación de Pauli de N qubits en lugar de Z tensor Z. Cuando solo tenemos matrices de Pauli Z,
podemos simplificar el circuit de esta manera, y lo que esto revela, algo que también se puede ver en las proyecciones que definen
la medición, es que realizar una medición Z tensor Z sobre dos qubits equivale a medir su paridad
pensando en términos de la base estándar, y esto se generaliza al producto tensorial de cualquier número de matrices Z de Pauli.
A continuación, revisaremos el código de repetición de tres bits, esta vez formulándolo en términos de operaciones de Pauli.
Este será nuestro primer ejemplo, bastante simple, de un código estabilizador, y veremos cómo generalizar esta
noción en breve, pero primero es útil ver cómo funciona en este caso simple. Recuerda que cuando aplicamos el
código de repetición de 3 bits a qubits, codificamos un estado qubit dado, alfa 0 más beta 1, como alfa 000 más beta 111
y llamaremos psi a esta codificación de tres qubits por conveniencia. Así que por definición, psi es una codificación válida de tres qubits
de un estado qubit, pero si queremos verificarlo, basta con comprobar que las dos ecuaciones siguientes son verdaderas. La
primera ecuación establece que aplicar operaciones Z a los dos qubits de la izquierda de psi no hace nada a psi, es decir, que
psi es un vector propio de Z tensor Z tensor Identidad, o simplemente ZZ identidad, con valor propio uno. Y la segunda
ecuación es similar, salvo que las operaciones Z se aplican a los dos qubits de la derecha. La idea es que si pensamos en psi
como una combinación lineal de estados de la base estándar, la primera ecuación implica que solo podemos tener coeficientes no nulos para estados de la base estándar
donde los dos bits de la izquierda tienen paridad par, o equivalentemente, son iguales; y la segunda ecuación implica que solo podemos
tener coeficientes no nulos para estados de la base estándar en los que los dos bits de la derecha tienen paridad par. Otra forma de pensar en esto
es ver estas dos operaciones de Pauli como observables, y si midiéramos estos dos observables usando el
circuit simplificado que mencioné hace un momento, estaríamos seguros de obtener un resultado de medición correspondiente a valores propios más uno,
ya que psi es un vector propio de ambos observables con valor propio uno. Pero esta versión simplificada del
circuit combinado para medir los observables de forma independiente no es más que nuestro circuit de comprobación de paridad para el código de 3 bits
el código de repetición, y así vemos que nuestras dos ecuaciones juntas son equivalentes a que el circuit de verificación de paridad produzca 0 0
que es el síndrome que indica que no se han detectado errores; las tres operaciones de Pauli sobre qubits
ZZ identidad e identidad ZZ se llaman generadores del estabilizador para este código, y el estabilizador del código es el conjunto
generado por los generadores del estabilizador; este conjunto, el estabilizador, es un objeto matemático fundamentalmente importante
asociado a este código, y seguiremos analizando el papel que desempeña a medida que avance la lección; por ahora
solo quiero señalar que podríamos haber elegido generadores distintos; por ejemplo, podríamos haber seleccionado Z identidad Z en lugar de cualquiera de
los generadores que sí seleccionamos, y el código y el estabilizador serían exactamente los mismos; a continuación consideraremos la detección de bit flip
en el código de repetición de tres bits, con énfasis en las interacciones y relaciones entre las operaciones de Pauli
involucradas, es decir, los generadores del estabilizador y los propios errores; supongamos que hemos codificado un
qubit usando el código de repetición de tres bits y que ocurre un error de bit flip en el qubit más a la izquierda; esto hace que nuestro estado psi sea
transformado según la acción de una operación X, o error X, sobre el qubit más a la izquierda; como ya sabemos, podemos detectar
este error realizando las verificaciones de paridad del código de repetición de tres bits, o de forma equivalente podemos medir la
codificación de manera no destructiva tratando los generadores del estabilizador como observables; empecemos con el primero
de los generadores del estabilizador y veamos qué ocurre; nuestro estado ha sido afectado por un error X y nos gustaría entender
cómo la medición del generador del estabilizador como observable se ve influida por este error; X y Z anticonmutan, mientras que
todo conmuta con la matriz identidad, por lo que se deduce que ZZ identidad anticonmuta con X identidad
identidad; así que obtenemos un signo menos cuando se cambia el orden, y también sabemos que ZZ identidad no hace nada a S
porque S es una codificación válida de un qubit y las codificaciones válidas son siempre vectores propios de valor +1 de ambos generadores del estabilizador
eso nos deja con X identidad identidad negativo aplicado a S, y por tanto X identidad identidad aplicado a
S es un vector propio de ZZ identidad con valor propio menos uno; también podemos hacer algo similar
con el segundo generador del estabilizador, pero esta vez el error conmuta con el generador del estabilizador, por lo que nuestro
estado corrupto es de nuevo un vector propio del generador del estabilizador, pero esta vez el valor propio es positivo
uno; así que nuestro estado corrupto es un vector propio de ambos generadores del estabilizador, y si el valor propio es +1 o
menos uno viene determinado por si el error conmuta o anticonmuta con cada generador del estabilizador; para el primero
el error y el generador del estabilizador anticonmutan, y para el segundo conmutan; y siempre será una cosa u la otra, porque cualesquiera dos
operaciones de Pauli o bien conmutan o bien anticonmutan; mientras tanto, el estado real psi no juega un papel importante
aquí, salvo por el hecho de que los generadores del estabilizador actúan de forma trivial sobre ese estado; así que cuando pensamos en la
detección de errores, realmente no necesitamos preocuparnos por el estado codificado específico; lo único que importa es si el error conmuta o anti-
conmuta con cada generador del estabilizador; así que hagamos una tabla con una fila por cada generador del estabilizador
y una columna por cada error; aquí solo he incluido los errores correspondientes a un único bit flip, así como
la ausencia de error, que se indica mediante la identidad tensada consigo misma tres veces; podríamos añadir más columnas para otros errores si quisiéramos
pero por ahora nos centraremos solo en estos errores; la entrada de la tabla es +1 o menos uno dependiendo de
si el error y el generador del estabilizador conmutan o anticonmutan; así que para cada error de la tabla podemos mirar
la columna correspondiente para ver cómo ese error transformará cualquier codificación dada en un vector propio de valor +1 o menos uno
de cada generador del estabilizador; estas columnas se corresponden exactamente con el síndrome que obtendríamos a partir de las
verificaciones de paridad, que son equivalentes a las mediciones no destructivas de los generadores del estabilizador como
observables; por supuesto, las entradas de esta tabla son +1 y menos uno en lugar de ceros y unos respectivamente
y si lo prefieres, puedes pensar en los síndromes como las cadenas binarias correspondientes en lugar de columnas de +1 y menos uno, pero hay una
correspondencia directa; y para hacer la conexión entre los síndromes y los valores propios más clara y directa
voy a llamar a estos vectores de +1 y menos uno síndromes; como antes, los síndromes nos dicen
algo sobre el error que haya ocurrido; en particular, si sabemos que ocurrió uno de estos cuatro errores posibles
el síndrome nos indica cuál fue, y podemos corregirlo aplicando el error de nuevo; si así lo
decidimos; a continuación diré solo un poco más sobre los síndromes, y en particular veremos más de cerca
sus aspectos algebraicos; nuestras codificaciones son estados de tres qubits, por lo que son vectores unitarios en un
espacio vectorial complejo de ocho dimensiones; y lo que hacen los cuatro síndromes posibles es dividir este espacio de ocho dimensiones
en cuatro subespacios bidimensionales, lo que significa que los vectores de cualquiera de estos subespacios siempre nos darán el mismo
síndrome; con más detalle, este diagrama ilustra cómo se divide el espacio de ocho dimensiones
cada generador del estabilizador divide el espacio en dos subespacios de igual dimensión, concretamente el espacio de vectores propios de valor +1
y el espacio de vectores propios de valor menos uno; por ejemplo, los vectores de valor +1 de ZZ identidad son combinaciones lineales
de estados de la base estándar en los que los dos bits más a la izquierda tienen paridad par, y los vectores propios de valor menos uno son combinaciones lineales
de estados de la base estándar en los que los dos bits más a la izquierda tienen paridad impar; y la situación es similar para
el otro generador del estabilizador, salvo que son los dos bits más a la derecha en lugar de los dos más a la izquierda; así que estos cuatro subespacios son fáciles de
describir en este caso, gracias a que se trata de un código muy simple; en particular, el subespacio
correspondiente al síndrome +1, +1 es el espacio generado por |000⟩ y |111⟩, que es el espacio de las
codificaciones válidas, y se llama espacio del código; en general, los espacios están generados por los estados de la base estándar
que se muestran en los cuadrados correspondientes, aunque no necesariamente es tan claro o fácil de ver; los síndromes
también particionan todas las operaciones de Pauli de tres qubits, que representan los posibles errores de Pauli que pueden ocurrir, en cuatro colecciones de igual tamaño
dependiendo de qué síndrome causaría ese error; por ejemplo, cualquier operación de Pauli
que conmute con ambos generadores del estabilizador produce el síndrome +1, +1; y entre los 64 posibles
operaciones de Pauli de tres qubits, hay exactamente 16 en esta categoría, incluyendo las tres que se mencionan en pantalla; e igualmente para los otros tres
síndromes; no es obvio, pero es cierto; y esta propiedad básica de que los síndromes particionan tanto el espacio de estados
en el que viven las codificaciones como todos los posibles errores de Pauli del espacio en piezas de igual tamaño es algo que
es cierto en general para los códigos estabilizadores, que pronto definiremos con precisión; aunque es principalmente un aparte por
vale la pena mencionar que las operaciones de Pauli que conmutan con ambos generadores del estabilizador, o de forma equivalente,
las operaciones de Pauli que producen el síndrome +1 +1 pero que no son proporcionales a elementos del estabilizador resultan comportarse igual que
operaciones de Pauli de un solo qubit sobre el qubit lógico que codificamos; por ejemplo, XXX conmuta con
ambos generadores del estabilizador pero no es proporcional a ningún elemento del estabilizador y, de hecho, está claro si
piensas en este código un momento que el efecto que tiene esta operación sobre una codificación es equivalente a un gate X sobre
el qubit lógico que se codificó, y de nuevo esto es algo que se generaliza a todos los códigos estabilizadores. Ahora es momento de definir los códigos estabilizadores
en general, y la forma en que funciona es que hacemos algo completamente análogo a lo que acabamos de discutir para
el código de repetición de tres bits, salvo que elegimos diferentes generadores del estabilizador, a los que me referiré como P1
hasta PR. Para esta explicación, estos generadores del estabilizador deben ser todos operaciones de Pauli de N qubits,
donde N es el número de qubits usados para la codificación, y no podemos elegir cualquier conjunto de generadores del estabilizador; deben
cumplir unas pocas condiciones básicas. Primero, los generadores del estabilizador deben conmutar todos entre sí.
En el caso del código de repetición de tres bits no nos molestamos en señalar esto, pero es sencillo observar que ZZ identidad e identidad
ZZ sí conmutan, porque Z conmuta consigo mismo y todo conmuta con la
identidad. Para códigos estabilizadores con generadores del estabilizador más complejos, en cambio, incluidos los códigos donde tenemos
tanto X como Z en los generadores del estabilizador, esta es una condición importante que hay que
verificar. Una forma de entender la necesidad de esta condición es que vamos a tratar los generadores del estabilizador como observables, y al exigir que
todos conmuten nos aseguramos de que el orden en que realizamos estas mediciones no
importe. Segundo, los generadores del estabilizador deben formar un conjunto generador minimal, lo que significa que si eliminamos cualquier
uno de ellos obtendríamos un estabilizador más pequeño, y una forma de expresar esto matemáticamente se muestra aquí en la
pantalla. Hablando con rigor, esta condición no es realmente esencial para el funcionamiento de un código estabilizador en un sentido operativo
y a veces tiene sentido pensar en conjuntos generadores no minimales, como veremos en la siguiente lección, pero
para analizar los códigos estabilizadores y explicar sus propiedades vamos a asumir que esta condición se
cumple. Básicamente, esta condición garantiza que cada observable que medimos para obtener el síndrome está aportando
información sobre posibles errores, en lugar de ser redundante y dar resultados que podrían inferirse fácilmente a partir de los otros generadores del estabilizador como
observables. Y por último, debe darse el caso de que al menos un vector no nulo sea fijo por todos
los generadores del estabilizador, lo que resulta equivalente a exigir que -1 por la identidad sobre N qubits no esté
contenida en el estabilizador. Eso no es obvio, pero el punto es que es posible elegir un conjunto generador minimal
de operaciones de Pauli de N qubits que conmuten todas entre sí y sin embargo ningún vector sea simultáneamente un autovector de +1
de todas ellas, y no queremos preocuparnos por esta posibilidad porque los códigos donde no hay ninguna codificación válida no son
interesantes. Así que esos son los requisitos sobre los generadores del estabilizador para un código estabilizador, y si tenemos un conjunto de generadores que
satisfacen estas condiciones entonces tenemos un código estabilizador válido y podemos estudiar sus propiedades. Hay muchos
códigos estabilizadores distintos con diversas propiedades que los hacen más o menos interesantes, pero todos satisfacen ciertas propiedades básicas
que recuerdan a las que ya observamos para el código de repetición de tres bits.
Veremos algunos ejemplos en breve, pero antes déjame mencionar que cuando hablamos del espacio de código de un código estabilizador nos referimos al subespacio
del espacio de estados de N qubits que incluye todo vector que sea simultáneamente un autovector de +1 de cada uno de los
generadores del estabilizador. Este es el subespacio del espacio de estados de N qubits en el que viven las codificaciones válidas, y tendremos más que
decir sobre este subespacio conforme continúe la lección. Ahora veamos algunos ejemplos de códigos estabilizadores.
Aquí está el ejemplo que ya hemos discutido: el código de repetición de 3 bits ordinario, y también podemos expresar la
versión modificada de ese código de la lección anterior, que puede detectar un error de fase en lugar de un error de bit, como un código estabilizador, tal como se muestra
aquí. Esta vez los generadores del estabilizador miden observables XX en lugar de ZZ, por lo que son básicamente
comprobaciones de paridad en la base más-menos en lugar de en la base estándar. En ambos casos podemos
ver de inmediato que tenemos un código estabilizador válido porque los generadores del estabilizador conmutan, estos son conjuntos
generadores minimales y el espacio de código es no trivial, como ya sabemos. Pero también podemos ver con bastante claridad que
no podemos generar -1 por la identidad. Y aquí está el código de Shor de 9 qubits, que también es un código estabilizador
expresado mediante generadores del estabilizador. En este caso tenemos básicamente tres copias del código de repetición de tres
bits, una para cada uno de los tres bloques de tres qubits, así como los dos últimos generadores del estabilizador, que
adoptan una forma reminiscente del circuit que vimos en la lección anterior para detectar errores de fase. Para este
código, otra forma de pensar en estos dos últimos generadores del estabilizador es que adoptan exactamente la misma forma que la que
tenemos para el código de repetición de tres bits para errores de fase, salvo que sustituimos XXX por X, y la razón de
esto es que XXX corresponde a una operación X sobre el qubit lógico codificado mediante el código de repetición de 3 bits, pero
eso es un inciso y no es algo en lo que debas preocuparte ahora. Por si no queda claro, a continuación veremos algunos
ejemplos más, pero antes déjame mencionar que la gente suele omitir los símbolos del producto tensorial al describir los códigos estabilizadores porque tiende a
hacer la lectura más fácil. Así que así es como quedan estos códigos sin los símbolos del producto tensorial.
Pero claro, estos son productos tensoriales y no productos de matrices ordinarios; simplemente estamos omitiendo los símbolos del producto tensorial para que sea menos
recargado y los patrones sean más claros. Aquí hay otro ejemplo: se llama
el código de Steane de 7 qubits y tiene algunas características bastante notables. Volveremos a este
de vez en cuando a lo largo de las lecciones restantes de la unidad, pero por ahora simplemente podemos verificar que es un código estabilizador válido.
En particular, los tres primeros generadores del estabilizador conmutan claramente entre sí porque Z conmuta consigo
mismo y la identidad conmuta con todo, y la situación es similar para los tres últimos, así que lo que queda es
comprobar que si tomamos uno de los generadores del estabilizador Z y uno de los generadores del estabilizador X entonces conmutan,
y es suficientemente fácil repasar los nueve emparejamientos posibles para verificar que en todos estos casos siempre
tendremos un X y un Z coincidiendo en la misma posición un número par de veces, por lo que los dos generadores conmutarán.
como xx y ZZ conmutan, es un conjunto generador mínimo y tiene un espacio de código no trivial, pero
no voy a intentar argumentar eso en este video; en cambio, te lo dejo para que pienses si quieres. El código Steane de 7 qubits es similar
al código Shore de 9 qubits en el sentido de que codifica un único qubit y permite corregir un error arbitrario en un qubit, pero solo
requiere siete qubits en lugar de nueve. Ese no es el menor número de qubits necesario para que un código corrector de errores
codifique un qubit y corrija un error arbitrario en un único qubit. Aquí hay un código estabilizador que
generalmente se llama simplemente el código de 5 qubits, que también codifica un único qubit y puede corregir un error arbitrario en un solo qubit.
Y cinco es el menor número de qubits para el que esto es posible. Aquí hay otro ejemplo de un
código estabilizador, aunque en realidad no es un código como tal, en el sentido de que el espacio de código es
unidimensional. En particular, el espacio de código de este código es el espacio generado por un ebit, o en otras palabras, un estado phi más
de Bell. Así que en realidad no puedes codificar ningún qubit usando este código, pero sigue siendo un código estabilizador válido donde el espacio de
código resulta ser unidimensional. Y es posible hacer algo similar para un estado GHZ.
Entonces esos son algunos ejemplos de códigos estabilizadores, y veremos infinitamente más ejemplos en la
siguiente lección. Supongamos que nos dan un código estabilizador. Una pregunta natural que hacerse sobre él,
quizás la primera pregunta que se te ocurra, es: ¿cuántos qubits codifica? Esa pregunta tiene una respuesta muy sencilla.
Para explicarla, seamos precisos sobre el código estabilizador que se está considerando. Tenemos n qubits y
generadores estabilizadores P1 hasta Pr que satisfacen los tres requisitos que mencioné antes, a saber, que los
generadores estabilizadores conmutan entre sí, que es un conjunto generador mínimo, por lo que no obtendríamos el mismo
estabilizador si elimináramos uno de los generadores, y que hay al menos un vector no nulo en el espacio de
código. Como indica el teorema mostrado en pantalla, debe ser entonces que el espacio de código del código estabilizador tiene
dimensión 2 elevado a n menos r. O dicho de otra manera, podemos codificar n
menos r qubits usando este código. Intuitivamente hablando, tenemos n qubits en nuestra codificación y cada
generador estabilizador efectivamente elimina un qubit en términos de cuántos qubits podemos codificar.
Este teorema no es demasiado difícil de demostrar, y te mostraré una demostración en un momento, pero primero veremos solo
algunos ejemplos, comenzando con el código de repetición de 3 bits ordinario. Tenemos tres qubits en nuestra
codificación, así que n es igual a tres, y hay R igual a 2 generadores estabilizadores, por lo que podemos codificar un
qubit usando este código. Observa que esto no tiene que ver con qué errores o cuántos errores se pueden detectar o
corregir; eso es un asunto diferente. Esto es simplemente una afirmación sobre la dimensión del espacio de código.
Para otro ejemplo, considera el código de 5 qubits. Aquí tenemos cinco qubits y cuatro
generadores estabilizadores, por lo que de nuevo el espacio de código tiene dimensión dos, lo que significa que podemos codificar un qubit usando este
código. Y un ejemplo más por ahora: para el código estabilizador del ebit, tenemos dos qubits y dos generadores estabilizadores, así que
el espacio de código es unidimensional y, como mencioné antes, es el espacio generado por el estado de Bell phi más.
Veremos más ejemplos a medida que avancemos, incluyendo códigos donde podemos codificar más de un qubit, pero por ahora
veamos cómo podemos demostrar el teorema. Lo primero que necesitamos observar es que, dado que los generadores
estabilizadores conmutan y forman un conjunto generador mínimo, y dado que toda operación de Pauli es su propio inverso, cada
elemento del estabilizador puede expresarse de forma única como un producto en el que elevamos cada generador estabilizador
Pk a la potencia ak, donde cada ak es cero o uno, y luego multiplicamos los resultados.
Otra forma de decirlo es que obtenemos cada elemento del estabilizador multiplicando juntos algún subconjunto de
los generadores estabilizadores, y nunca obtenemos el mismo elemento del estabilizador de subconjuntos diferentes. Y una cosa que
esto implica es que la única forma de expresar la operación identidad de n qubits de esta manera es hacer que todas las potencias sean
cero. A continuación, definamos pi k como la proyección sobre el subespacio propio de +1 de Pk para cada k de 1 a r. Y hay
una fórmula sencilla para esta proyección: podemos simplemente promediar Pk con la identidad en n qubits, lo que efectivamente deja los
valores propios +1 intactos y lleva todos los valores propios -1 a cero.
Ahora, el espacio de código se define como el conjunto de todos los vectores que son simultáneamente vectores propios de +1 de todos
los generadores estabilizadores. Dado que los generadores estabilizadores conmutan, las proyecciones también deben conmutar, y eso
implica que el producto de estas proyecciones es también una proyección, y en particular es la proyección sobre la
intersección de los subespacios sobre los que proyectan las proyecciones individuales, o en otras palabras, es la proyección sobre
el espacio de código. Podemos expandir este producto y lo que obtenemos es el promedio sobre cada
elemento del estabilizador. Y finalmente, dado que la dimensión de cualquier subespacio es igual a
la traza de la proyección sobre ese subespacio, encontramos que la dimensión del espacio de código es el promedio de las trazas sobre los elementos del
estabilizador. Pero con la excepción de la operación identidad de n qubits, todos los elementos del estabilizador deben tener
traza igual a cero, porque las tres matrices de Pauli no identidad tienen traza igual a cero. La traza de la operación identidad de n qubits
es 2 elevado a n, y por eso encontramos que la dimensión del espacio de código es 2 elevado a n menos r, lo que demuestra el
teorema. A continuación, diré solo un poco sobre cómo se pueden codificar qubits usando códigos estabilizadores, pero para eso primero
necesitamos introducir las operaciones de Clifford. Las operaciones de Clifford son operaciones unitarias sobre cualquier número de
qubits que pueden implementarse mediante circuits cuánticos con un conjunto restringido de gates, concretamente gates Hadamard, gates S
y gates CNOT. Observa que los gates T no están incluidos, ni los gates de Toffoli ni los gates de Fredkin.
Y no solo esos gates no están en esta lista, sino que de hecho no es posible implementar esos gates
usando los que se enumeran aquí, por lo que no son operaciones de Clifford. Las operaciones de Pauli, por otro lado,
sí son operaciones de Clifford, y específicamente pueden implementarse usando secuencias de gates Hadamard y S.
Así que esa es una forma sencilla de definir las operaciones de Clifford, pero no explica realmente por qué se definen de
esta manera o qué tiene de especial esta colección particular de gates. Aquí está la razón real por la que las operaciones de Clifford se definen así:
salvo una fase global, las operaciones de Clifford de n qubits son precisamente las operaciones unitarias
que siempre transforman operaciones de Pauli en operaciones de Pauli por conjugación. Para ser más precisos, una operación de n qubits
la operación unitaria U es una operación Clifford salvo una fase global si y solo si para todo n-qubit poly
la operación de conjugar esa operación poly por U nos da más o menos uno por alguna operación poly de n
qubits posiblemente diferente. Puedes verificar fácilmente que esta propiedad se cumple para los Hadamard gates, S
gates y CNOT gates, por lo que necesariamente se cumple para circuits construidos a partir de estos gates. Lo más difícil de demostrar es que también se cumple
en la dirección contraria: que si se nos da una operación unitaria de n qubits U que satisface esta
propiedad, entonces debe ser posible implementarla salvo una fase global usando únicamente gates Hadamard, S y CNOT.
No voy a ver la demostración de esa implicación, pero es cierta y puedes buscarla si tienes
curiosidad. Las operaciones Clifford no son universales para la computación cuántica, lo que significa que no podemos ejecutar computaciones arbitrarias
usando únicamente gates Hadamard, S y CNOT. De hecho, para un valor de n dado, solo hay un número finito de
operaciones Clifford de n qubits, así que es un conjunto discreto de operaciones. A diferencia de un
conjunto universal de quantum gates, no podemos aproximar operaciones unitarias arbitrarias con el nivel de precisión que queramos, y además
realizar operaciones Clifford sobre estados de la base estándar seguidas de mediciones en la base estándar no nos permite
realizar computaciones que estén fuera del alcance de los algoritmos clásicos, porque podemos simular eficientemente computaciones de esta forma
de forma clásica. Este hecho se conoce como el teorema de Gottesman-Knill, y la demostración estándar de ese teorema es, en cierto sentido,
está basada en el formalismo de estabilizadores. En particular, lo que hace es que podemos hacer un seguimiento de cómo las operaciones Clifford transforman las operaciones poly
por conjugación, lo cual se puede hacer de forma eficiente, y luego inferir a partir de eso qué hacen las computaciones a los
qubits. Entonces, ¿qué tiene que ver esto con los códigos estabilizadores? Bueno, un código estabilizador nos proporciona
un espacio de código de cierta dimensión, y tenemos libertad para usar ese espacio de código como queramos, así que nada nos obliga a codificar
qubits en ese espacio de una forma específica, pero siempre será posible realizar una codificación usando una operación Clifford
como codificador. Eso es conveniente porque las operaciones Clifford son relativamente simples comparadas con operaciones unitarias arbitrarias.
Hay formas de optimizar su implementación que funcionan siguiendo líneas similares a la demostración del teorema de Gottesman-
Knill, y como resultado los circuits para implementarlas nunca necesitan ser demasiado
grandes. En particular, siempre podemos realizar una codificación usando una operación Clifford que requiere un poco menos que un número cuadrático de gates,
porque eso es en realidad cierto para toda operación Clifford. Así que la conclusión es que para un código estabilizador dado, siempre es
posible codificar qubits de forma eficiente usando ese código, y las herramientas matemáticas útiles para entender las operaciones Clifford pueden ayudar con este
proceso. Por ejemplo, aquí hay un codificador para el código Steane de 7 qubits. Es una operación Clifford y, resulta que
este ni siquiera necesita S gates. Para códigos estabilizadores generales, la detección de errores funciona de la siguiente
manera. Como antes, supondremos que tenemos generadores estabilizadores de n qubits P1 hasta Pr, y sea E una operación poly de n qubits
que representa un error hipotético en una codificación. Solo estamos considerando operaciones poly
como errores, por cierto, porque la discretización de errores funciona de la misma manera para códigos estabilizadores arbitrarios que para el código Shor de 9 qubits.
La forma en que verificamos errores es medir cada uno de los generadores estabilizadores como
observables. Hay R generadores estabilizadores, así que esto significa R resultados, donde cada uno es más uno o menos
uno, o un valor binario si prefieres asociar cero con más uno y uno con menos uno, y estos R resultados
juntos forman el síndrome, igual que teníamos para el código de repetición de tres bits cuando R era igual a
dos. En general hay tres casos posibles para el error E en términos de su detección, y son los siguientes. Primero,
podría ocurrir que E esté en el estabilizador, es decir, que sea posible generar E a partir de los generadores estabilizadores, o
de forma un poco más general, podría ocurrir que E sea equivalente a un elemento estabilizador salvo una fase
global. En este caso E realmente no es un error en absoluto, porque no tiene ningún efecto en el espacio de código salvo posiblemente
introducir una fase global, lo cual no tiene ningún efecto. Así que no necesitamos preocuparnos para nada por errores como este. Cualquier
acción no trivial que pueda tener ocurre fuera del espacio de código, así que no nos importa.
Mucho más preocupante es la posibilidad de que E no esté en el estabilizador, ni siquiera salvo una fase global, pero
sin embargo conmute con cada uno de nuestros generadores estabilizadores. Recuerda que es la
anticonmutación del error con un generador estabilizador lo que hace que aparezca un menos uno en algún lugar del síndrome,
pero eso no ocurre en este caso. Así que este es un error que realmente sí cambia los vectores del espacio de código de alguna forma
no trivial, y lo sabemos porque de lo contrario sería proporcional a un elemento estabilizador, pero pasa
desapercibido para el código. Así que este es el caso malo: tenemos un error que potencialmente está cambiando
la información cuántica que hemos codificado, pero el código no se da cuenta de este hecho. Por ejemplo, para el código de repetición de tres bits,
XXX entra en esta categoría. Y la última posibilidad es que E
anticonmute con al menos uno de los generadores estabilizadores, lo que significa que el código detecta este error porque
obtendremos un síndrome con al menos un menos uno en algún lugar, lo que indica que algo va mal y necesitaremos intentar corregir este error
de alguna manera. Así que esas son las posibilidades. Como punto de terminología,
cuando nos referimos a la distancia de un código estabilizador, lo que queremos decir es el peso mínimo de una operación poly que cae
en la segunda categoría, es decir, que cambia el espacio de código de alguna forma no trivial pero el código no
lo detecta. Y cuando decimos que un código estabilizador es un código estabilizador [[n,m,d]], usando
dobles corchetes como se muestra en pantalla, lo que significa es que las codificaciones tienen una longitud de n qubits,
el código es capaz de codificar m qubits, así que el espacio de código tiene dimensión 2 elevado a m, y su distancia es d. Así que un error tiene que
tener peso d o más para cambiar el estado lógico de cualquier qubit que hayamos codificado sin ser detectado como un
error. Ahora vamos a ver el código Steane de 7 qubits como ejemplo y vamos a determinar cuál es su distancia.
Aquí están los generadores estabilizadores para este código, y recuerda que la distancia es el peso mínimo de una
operación poly de n qubits que conmuta con todos los generadores estabilizadores pero no está en el estabilizador ni
es proporcional a un elemento del estabilizador. Lo que vamos a determinar es que este código tiene distancia
tres. La forma en que lo vamos a determinar es considerar primero cualquier operación poly con peso como máximo dos, y
concluir que la única forma en que puede computar con los seis generadores del estabilizador es que sea la identidad, que siempre es un elemento del
estabilizador. Supongamos entonces que las matrices de Pauli posiblemente no identidad que forman esta operación, que llamaremos
P y Q, aparecen en las dos posiciones más a la izquierda. Este es solo un caso y tenemos que
considerar todas las demás ubicaciones posibles para estas matrices de Pauli posiblemente no identidad, pero el argumento es básicamente el mismo para todas
las ubicaciones posibles. Bueno, por hipótesis, esta operación conmuta con todos los
generadores del estabilizador, así que en particular conmuta con este y también conmuta con este.
Q se alinea con la matriz identidad en ambos generadores, por eso elegimos estos dos, y tenemos matrices
identidad en las cinco posiciones más a la derecha de este error, por lo que concluimos que P debe conmutar con tanto X
como Z, porque de lo contrario este error anticonmutaría con uno de estos dos generadores. Pero la única matriz de Pauli que
conmuta con tanto X como Z es la identidad, así que P debe ser la identidad. Y ahora que lo sabemos,
podemos elegir dos generadores del estabilizador más que tienen una X y una Z en la segunda posición desde la izquierda, y podemos
sacar una conclusión similar sobre Q. Así que no hay forma de que un error de peso a lo sumo 2 pase desapercibido por este código
a menos que sea simplemente la operación identidad, que está en el estabilizador, por lo que en realidad no es un
error. Por otro lado, hay operaciones de Pauli de peso tres que conmutan con los seis generadores del estabilizador
pero no son proporcionales a elementos del estabilizador, y aquí hay dos ejemplos. Así que hemos concluido que este
código tiene distancia tres. Lo último que discutiremos en esta lección es la corrección de errores para
códigos estabilizadores. Como de costumbre, asumiremos que nuestro código está especificado por generadores del estabilizador de n bits
P1 hasta Pn. Empecemos pensando un poco sobre todos los errores posibles que podrían
ocurrir. Hay dos elevado a r síndromes posibles y, como mencioné antes en la lección, estos síndromes particionan todos
los posibles operaciones de Pauli de n qubits en colecciones de igual tamaño, lo que significa 4 elevado a N dividido por 2 elevado a r operaciones de Pauli
dentro de cada conjunto. Así que cuando vemos un síndrome particular, podría ser que cualquiera de estos cuatro elevado a N dividido por 2
elevado a r errores sea el responsable. Estamos contando de más un poco aquí, porque algunos de estos
errores tienen exactamente el mismo efecto en el espacio del código. En particular, si tenemos un error E y multiplicamos E por cualquier
elemento del estabilizador S, vamos a obtener otro error que tiene exactamente el mismo efecto en el espacio del código que E. Así que
estos son errores equivalentes. El estabilizador tiene dos elevado a r elementos, y si tenemos esto en cuenta, encontramos
que para cada síndrome hay cuatro elevado a N menos r clases de equivalencia de errores que podrían haber causado ese
síndrome. Y lo que eso significa es que, a menos que R sea igual a n, en cuyo caso tenemos un espacio del código de una dimensión y
por lo tanto no podemos codificar ningún qubit, no va a ser posible corregir todos los errores que podemos detectar. En cambio,
lo que tenemos que hacer es elegir solo una operación de corrección para cada síndrome, con la esperanza de corregir solo una clase de errores equivalentes.
¿Cómo debemos elegir qué corrección realizar para cada síndrome? Una estrategia natural es elegir
la operación de Pauli de menor peso que cause el síndrome que medimos, con la idea de que las operaciones de Pauli de menor peso
representan explicaciones más probables para ese síndrome. En realidad, esto podría no ser así
para algunos modelos de ruido, y otra estrategia natural es calcular de alguna manera el error más probable que cause el
síndrome dado. Pero por ahora solo consideraremos la estrategia en la que intentamos corregir errores seleccionando la operación de Pauli de menor peso que cause el
síndrome. Para un código estabilizador de distancia D, esta estrategia siempre nos permitirá corregir errores de peso estrictamente
menor que la mitad de D, o en otras palabras, de peso a lo sumo (D menos 1) dividido por 2. Y explicaré brevemente por qué.
Esto mostrará, por ejemplo, que el código Steane de 7 qubits puede corregir cualquier error de Pauli de peso uno, y gracias a la
discretización de errores, eso significa que, al igual que el código Shore de 9 qubits, el código Steane puede corregir un
error arbitrario en un qubit. Así es como funciona: considera que este círculo representa todas las posibles operaciones de Pauli
que resultan en el síndrome de todos más uno, que es el síndrome que sugiere que no han ocurrido errores
y que todo está bien. Entre estas operaciones tenemos elementos del estabilizador, o más bien
operaciones proporcionales a elementos del estabilizador, y también tenemos errores no triviales que cambian el espacio del código de alguna manera, pero no son
detectados por el código. Y sabemos, por la definición de distancia, que cada operación de Pauli en esta categoría debe tener peso al menos
D, porque D se define como el peso mínimo de estas operaciones. También tenemos operaciones de Pauli
que hacen aparecer otros síndromes, y podríamos considerar cada síndrome por turno si quisiéramos, pero aquí simplemente imaginamos
que ha aparecido un síndrome S. Ahora imagina que E es un error en esta
categoría que tiene peso estrictamente menor que la mitad de la distancia D. Bueno, no sabemos que esto sea
necesariamente la operación de Pauli de menor peso en este círculo, así que tomemos C como la operación de menor peso en este conjunto, o una de ellas en caso de empate.
Podría ser que C sea igual a E o posiblemente no, pero como C tiene
peso mínimo, sabemos que no puede tener peso mayor que el peso de E, porque C también está en el conjunto
y tiene peso mínimo. Así que la operación de corrección C debe tener peso estrictamente menor que la mitad de
D. ¿Qué ocurre entonces si aplicamos esta corrección C a cualquier estado que resulte después del error E?
La respuesta es que el estado que obtenemos es C multiplicado por E aplicado a la codificación original, porque primero
multiplicamos por E, que fue el error, y luego multiplicamos por C para intentar corregirlo. Y este producto debe estar en
el estabilizador o ser proporcional a un elemento del estabilizador. Y aquí está el porqué: primero, porque E y C nos dan el
mismo síndrome, C multiplicado por E debe darnos el síndrome de todos más uno. Eso es porque para un
generador del estabilizador dado, o bien C y E ambos conmutan con ese generador, o ambos anticonmutan. Tiene que ser igual para
ambos porque los síndromes son los mismos. Y si lo piensas por un momento, eso implica que C multiplicado por E debe
conmutar con todos los generadores del estabilizador. Y finalmente, C multiplicado por E tiene que estar
en el estabilizador porque su peso no puede ser mayor que la suma de los pesos de C y E, así que su peso
es estrictamente menor que D. Y eso significa que corregimos E con éxito, porque aplicar E seguido de C no hace nada al
espacio del código. Eso es genial, pero hay solo un problema: para los códigos estabilizadores
en general, calcular la operación de menor peso que causa un síndrome dado es un problema computacionalmente difícil.
Y eso es cierto incluso para los códigos clásicos, que en este contexto podemos entender como códigos estabilizadores
donde solo aparecen matrices identidad y matrices de Pauli Z como factores tensoriales dentro del estabilizador.
Así que, a diferencia del paso de codificación, las operaciones de Clifford no vienen al rescate esta vez. Y la única solución razonable
es elegir códigos específicos para los que se puedan calcular buenas correcciones de manera eficiente. Y no hay una receta para
esto. En pocas palabras, diseñar códigos estabilizadores de este tipo es parte del arte
del diseño de códigos cuánticos. Y ese es un buen punto para terminar esta lección. Espero que te unas a mí
en la próxima lección, en la que veremos algunas construcciones de códigos cuánticos específicos, incluidos códigos que ilustran el arte del diseño de códigos cuánticos
de una manera bastante espectacular. Hasta pronto.